warning just got issued just now i was
just going to put this out on social
media but i had to run up here
and let you know about it this is in
this yellow box here look at the amount
of lightning strikes along with this so
this is clark county indian springs over
there this is right around county line
as this storm continues to bear down
south what we can expect from that
around this specific
area where we have that warning in
effect right now 70 mile per hour gusts
that's huge
moving south at 10 miles per hour power
outages are possible around those areas
and damaging winds of course as this
moves its way south
right now the warning is into southern
portions of lincoln county
and it's moving its way down into clark
county look at those storms there in
lincoln county all the way over into
utah too bearing down across the region
will they hold together that's the big
story but even if they don't
the outflow from that creates more
thunderstorms so we're now in the woods
just yet tonight we still have the
possibility
of more storms picked up 100 600 of an
inch of rain this morning
early early this morning that puts our
total to almost two tenths of an inch
that's above average so we'll take any
rain we can get there's a look right now
a closer look at the
radar showing those storms anytime you
get these purple colors here in the
white colors that's indicating heavy
rain coming down and even some hail i
bet you some hail along with this too
but you can see the amount of lightning
strikes along with this as it moves its
way down towards the south there's the
las vegas valley
now with the storms that we see there on
the radar and anything that develops
tonight
the conditions are just ripe to create
flash flooding
strong gusty winds we've seen that right
now you see that 70 mile per hour gusts
we've
pointed out to you lightning you saw the
lightning strikes and hail too that's
also a possibility
with these storms for this evening some
of them could be severe that one we just
pinpointed out to you severe and that's
the reason why
that severe thunderstorm warning was
just issued by the weather service 87
degrees overnight
scattered storms are going to be all
around for tonight i'm not going
anywhere i'm staying in
i'm going to be here watching that radar
getting on social media for you guys
strong outflow winds can be expected
from those storms as well so keep that
in mind 107 for tomorrow
mostly sunny skies tomorrow but still
enough moisture in the atmosphere
and enough convection and instability
where we could have some isolated
thunderstorms
mainly later on in the evening so keep
that in mind
here's your most accurate eight day
forecast the only place you'll find an
eight day forecast here in las vegas
isolated storms possible tomorrow drier
on thursday at least until saturday and
then notice
on sunday that monsoon starts to slowly
sneak its way back into the region
giving a slight chance as early as
sunday kind of like what we saw
this week right and then increases a
little more as we get through the week
with chances
again through tuesday and wednesday as
well
temperatures will be out of that
excessive heat but still remain hot
but at least near normal by the time we
get to sunday and monday
that is your most accurate forecast
brian over to you